all right guys I can't stop and won't
stop I have another coffee pot
while I do my makeup
get fat chicks off of planes
I am so tired of scrolling on Twitter
and seeing these morbidly obese women
okay you guys
can make fun of me all you want but this
is a travesty okay I need to
I need to find this
honestly fat chicks shouldn't even be
allowed to be this fat
in all honesty there should be attacks
because you're costing all the taxpayers
all your family everyone around you
money and honestly just uncomfortability
by being this overweight it like fat
chick plane there was this fat chick and
she was wobbling down this this plane
and she can't even get in her seat and
so now she's gonna sit down and her
roles are gonna go over onto the other
people's blubber
or on the other people's seats why
are they allowed on the plane if I was
the flight attendant I would say ma'am
get on this treadmill and come back in
three months
get on the treadmill
and and come back in three months
because this is not okay
yeah look at this if this is
discrimination she's saying this is
discrimination
how do you get to this point how I just
have questions okay
and it's unfortunate because we all won
okay we all have to see you so when
you're a big fat chick and you're like
walking around I have to look at you and
that's uncomfortable for me like you
guys know when you walk into a room and
the super super obese person comes in
and it's just uncomfortable for
everybody because you're so fat it's
like distracting and you almost feel bad
for their ankles because you're like
your ankles are gonna break it any
second and on top of that
you can't even walk and they're getting
out of breath just trying to take a
couple steps and we're the Bad Guys for
saying a fat chick is fat where the bad
guys for saying get these ladies off the
internet get them off of the magazines
and honestly get on the treadmill and
this would probably be the best outcome
for everybody
for everybody in all honesty but I'm the
bad guy because I call them whales
when in all honesty maybe you know
calling them whales would give them the
extra motivation
the extra motivation to stop being so
fat
it's like
guys look at this picture I just
couldn't look at this
look at this
like
laughs
and we're saying and then you know what
the you know what the craziest thing is
this woman has an only fans so not only
is this woman crazy obese
she gets to go make money off of her
looks why are you guys buying this
why
this perpetuates the problem all right
um maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm just a big
old meanie like they say I just dunk on
women
this is we need to bring fat shaving
back because that's shameful that's
absolutely crazy but let me know what
you think in the comments maybe I'm just
insane you know like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel I'll
talk to you next time